let's talk about that Super Bowl I have
to get this off my chest I have to say
something that was hard to watch and I'm
a Patriots fan seriously I was born and
raised in Massachusetts I've been a
lifelong Patriots fan I found that to be
what is the opposite of a nail-biter it
was an ale grower who thought I was
watching a baseball game that was rough
did you feel the same way like that was
just hard to why the Patriots have now
won six Super Bowls and I was I was
thing about this even if you're a fan
even if you're a fan they've won six
Super Bowls I think they should take a
season off they should backpack through
Europe you should get to know themselves
you don't I mean I think so yeah take a
gap year just walk around with is enough
enough enough
that's not how anyone in my family feels
you talked to people in Boston already
last night they're like we're gonna get
number seven and then we're gonna get
nothing
[Applause]
the storms gonna do it all are we
talking about just what they're never
happy yeah and then of course not happy
somewhat that halftime show
[Music]
yeah people weren't thrilled about
maroon 5 for the halftime show did you
notice this the stage was designed to
look like B letter M did you see that
apparently the M stood for maybe we
should have tried to get Beyonce what
about one big boy came out in a fur coat
you see that big boy came out in a fur
coat yet was from an animal that took
its own life during maroon 5 joke makes
no sense the animal took its own life
then quickly had itself made into a coat
over an eight minute period